Thanks hello I'm hands partner from the
Boston Consulting Group the question I
would like to address is it truly
possible to have free and fair trade
which protects both people and the
environment I think um we need to see
globalization as a win-win we see every
year 50 to 100 million new people
entering the global market yes kazuma's
as employees and workers as
entrepreneurs and I think they really
help to lift the standard of living of
the whole world and as we open up
markets as we are open to the
opportunities but also to the challenges
of globalization I think we all benefit
enormously and you know it will give
people the opportunities everywhere in
the world to participate and to make it
work for themselves for the societies
they live in anything for the roller
couch or the best